على بعد بضعه كيلومترات من شمال باخموت
بلده اخرى تقع في قبضه الروس وفق مجموعه
فاجنر المسلحه التي نشرت هذه الصور
سيطره الوحدات الهجوميه في فاجنر على بلده
كريس ناهورا في نطاق نحو 50 كيلومترا لا
يوجد سوى مقاتلي فاغنر الذين سيسيطرون على
ضخمه
هذا المستشفى الميداني المتنقل بالجنود
الاوكرانيين المصابين ننجح في اجلاء
جنودنا الجرحى من الخطوط الاماميه ونتمكن
من اسعافهم لكن من الصعب الحفاظ على
معنويات عاليه خاصه عندما نكون امام
اصابات خطيره للغايه ورغم ذلك نحاول ان
نرفع من معنويات المرضى في خطابه المسائي
وجه الرئيس الاوكراني رساله الى الجنود
على خط المواجهه ودعاهم الى الصمود في وجه
العدو من اجل اوكرانيا المجد لكل اولئك
الذين يدافعون عن باخموت وفوق ليدار وجميع
مدن دونسك وعلى طول خط المواجهه قوتنا هي
الصمود والوحده
بعد اكثر من سته اشهر من المعارك ما تزال
روسيا تحاول دخول باخمه المدمره بعد
اسابيع من تكثيف المعارك اعلن الروس عن
قطع العديد من الطرق المستخدمه في تزويد
القوات الاوكرانيه بالامدادات واكدوا
الاستيلاء على مدينه سوليدار القريبه في
الحادي عشر من كانون الثاني يناير